Transcription: Morgane Quilfen
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Il est quatre heures du matin.
Je suis sur une paroi dans les Alpes
à 3 800 mètres d'altitude.
Le couloir est raide, froid et verglacé.
Je progresse petit à petit
en pointes avant, avec mes piolets.
Il y a déjà 600 mètres de vide sous moi
et peut-être plus de 200 mètres
pour atteindre le sommet.
Ça fait plusieurs heures
qu'on est partis du refuge
pour tenter de gravir l'Aiguille Verte.
Soudain, j'ai une douleur fulgurante
dans le mollet droit,
suivie par une autre quatre secondes après
dans la cuisse droite.
Toute ma jambe se met à trembler.
Je me dépêche de sortir une broche à glace
et de m'assurer sur la paroi.
Et là, c'est ma jambe gauche
qui se tétanise complètement,
impossible à arrêter.
J'ai tellement mal que je suis
à deux doigts de m'évanouir.
Au bout d'un quart d'heure,
la douleur passe
et la cordée continue
sa progression dans la paroi.
Et en arrivant au sommet,
je me suis dit :
« Matthieu, plus jamais ça.
Tu vas t'améliorer. »
Bonsoir, je suis Matthieu Lentz,
je suis directeur marketing
dans le big data
et cofondateur d'une plateforme
d'acculturation
à l'intelligence artificielle.
Je ne suis pas un alpiniste professionnel,
mais je suis passionné
de haute montagne et d'ultra-trail.
Et je me suis demandé si,
en combinant mes constantes vitales
avec mes données biométriques
plus quelques données météo,
données satellites,
et quelques millions de données patients,
je ne pourrais pas créer
un algorithme d'intelligence artificielle
qui me fasse
une sorte de diagnostic prédictif
et, en temps réel,
il pourrait me dire par exemple :
« Hou la la, Matthieu, attention !
Ça ne va pas, tu es en manque de sel !
Fais quelque chose mon grand,
mange du saucisson ! »
Autrement dit :
est-ce que l'intelligence artificielle
peut nous améliorer
et nous aider à dépasser nos limites ?
Et est-ce que cela
concerne tout le monde ?
Ce soir, je vais vous livrer
mes réflexions sur le sujet.
L'IA, est-ce que cela
concerne tout le monde ?
A l'issue de ce TEDx, vous allez sortir,
vous allez rallumer vos portables,
hou la la, plein de notifications !
Insta pour les jeunes,
Facebook pour les vieux
et LinkedIn pour les fous du boulot.
Vous avez remarqué,
c'est une IA qui ne vous poste
dans votre fil d'actualités
que ce qui vous correspond réellement.
A la limite, peu importe,
on va se détendre,
on va aller profiter des soldes sur Amazon
qui non seulement sait ce que je préfère,
mais commence déjà à livrer le produit
avant même que je n'aie cliqué
sur le bouton « Acheter »
grâce à son algorithme d'IA prédictif.
L'IA, ça concerne tout le monde
et l'IA, ça va vite.
En 2018,
65 000 articles scientifiques
ont été publiés par les États-Unis,
la Chine et l'Europe réunis.
Deux fois plus qu'en 2015.
65 000, ce sont 180 articles par jour.
Sachant qu'on ne peut lire
qu'un article par jour -
un article, ce sont 15 à 30 pages
d'un anglais très technique,
il faut s'accrocher, croyez-moi -
on est déjà complètement dépassé.
Alors, et l'homme dans tout ça ?
L'homme augmenté,
ou la femme augmentée.
L'Homme augmenté.
L'Homme augmenté aujourd'hui,
c'est une réalité grâce à l'IA,
et cela porte un nom :
le « transhumanisme ».
Le transhumanisme, c'est un projet
d'amélioration de l'espèce humaine
sous toutes les formes,
que ce soit morale, intellectuelle,
physique ou émotionnelle.
Les membres bioniques,
l'utérus artificiel,
les exosquelettes, les implants cérébraux,
le rallongement de la durée de la vie,
la thérapie génique -
on prend le contrôle de notre apparence.
Ce qu'il faut bien comprendre,
c'est que l'Homme
est un être technologique.
Depuis des dizaines de milliers d'années,
il crée des outils pour pallier
les manques dont la nature l'a doté.
L'Homme est voué à s'améliorer.
Le philosophe
Jean-Jacques Rousseau disait :
« L'homme est un être perfectible. »
Et aujourd'hui, la technologie peut
donner à l'Homme un corps augmenté.
Ce soir, je vais vous donner
quatre exemples
pour bien comprendre la chose.
Premier exemple, on se trouve à Grenoble,
au centre de recherche Clinatec.
En 2019, un exosquelette a permis
à un patient tétraplégique de remarcher
grâce à une neuro-prothèse.
Le patient pense le mouvement
et la machine s'active.
Attention, c'est un système très simple.
On a entraîné le cerveau
des mois et des mois durant
à exhiber un certain nombre
d'états cérébraux
que la machine a ensuite
traduits en mouvement.
On est très loin
du contrôle par la pensée,
mais c'est assez extraordinaire.
Lorsque l'homme s'hybride avec la machine,
on appelle ça un homme « cyborg » :
un mélange d'organisme biologique
et de greffes mécaniques et électroniques.
Il y a six ans,
une entreprise française, Carmat,
réalisait la première
intervention chirurgicale
d'implantation d'un cœur artificiel total,
bio-prothétique, auto-régulé.
Aujourd'hui, c'est plus d'une douzaine
de patients en insuffisance cardiaque
qui vivent grâce à cette innovation.
L'Homme fonctionne désormais
grâce aux processus propres de la machine.
L'Homme fonctionne grâce à la machine.
Troisième exemple :
la rétinopathie diabétique.
En France, cela concerne
1,5 million de personnes.
C'est la première cause
de cécité avant 65 ans.
Une entreprise américaine a inventé une IA
capable de dépister cette dégénérescence
avant qu'elle n'arrive.
Le plus intéressant, ce n'est pas ça.
L'association américaine
du médicament, la FDA,
a autorisé pour la première
et unique fois au monde
ce dispositif médical à la vente.
Et en décembre 2019,
c'est l'association
américaine des diabétiques
qui va inclure cette IA autonome
dans ses standards de soins.
Concrètement, cela veut dire quoi
ce que je vous dis là ?
Ça veut dire que la machine
remplace le médecin
et c'est officiel.
C'est un standard.
C'est curieux, cela me rappelle quelqu'un
qui voulait développer
un algorithme d'IA pour la montagne.
Dernier exemple.
Selon l'INSEE, et si tout se passe bien,
s'il n'y a pas de guerre,
s'il n'y a pas de cataclysme,
s'il n'y a pas d'épidémie,
une petite fille née aujourd'hui
a 48% de chances de devenir centenaire.
Et grâce aux progrès
de la techno-médecine,
des recherches sur les cellules souches
ou des recherches sur les télomérases,
ces enzymes capables de prévenir
l'usure des chromosomes,
qui est un des facteurs de la vieillesse,
rien n'empêcherait de vivre
jusqu'à 120, 150 ans, voire plus,
comme le suggère Laurent Alexandre.
La mort est un problème
et on a une solution.
Alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
Est-ce qu'il faut continuer
à améliorer l'être humain
de manière artificielle ou pas ?
Ce qu'il faut que vous reteniez ce soir,
c'est qu'il y a deux camps qui s'opposent.
Vous avez d'un côté les bioprogressistes
voulant lutter contre les trois
fléaux de l'humanité :
la maladie, la vieillesse et la mort,
et de l'autre côté,
vous avez les bioconservateurs
pour lesquels la nature est sacrée :
la changer ou la modifier
revient à la destruction
de nos principes moraux fondamentaux.
Bioprogressistes, bioconservateurs,
les deux ont des arguments identiques.
Qu'est-ce que moi j'en ai retenu ?
L'Homme augmenté est déjà là,
qu'on le veuille ou non.
Il n'y a plus de différence
entre une médecine thérapeutique,
qui répare ce qui est cassé,
qui soigne la maladie
ou qui restaure l'équilibre,
et une médecine améliorative,
qui va stimuler notre système immunitaire,
qui va lutter contre
le processus de sénescence
ou qui va améliorer notre silhouette.
Et aujourd'hui,
il n'y a rien
qui empêcherait la machine
de dépasser l'Homme
sur tous les grands principes de pensée
comme l'imagination,
la synthèse
ou l’intentionnalité,
qui est le fait
d'être conscient d'exister.
La machine nous a déjà dépassés
sur la déduction et l'induction.
Est-ce que je vais développer
mon algorithme d'intelligence artificielle
pour m'aider à gravir les sommets ?
Eh bien, non.
Je ne vais pas le développer.
Je laisse l'idée à d'autres.
Parce que ce qui m'intéresse, moi,
dans la montagne et l'alpinisme,
ce n'est pas le classement,
ce n'est pas l'efficacité à tout prix,
ce n'est pas d'atteindre
le sommet à chaque fois,
c'est vraiment de me sentir vivant,
avec mes propres limites.
Et ce sont ces limites, justement,
qui me motivent
pour essayer de les dépasser.
Et par rapport à la machine,
j'ai quelque chose qu'elle n'aura jamais,
mais jamais,
c'est-à-dire un corps.
Le corps est capable de choses incroyables
si on l'écoute.
Faites-lui confiance,
car il se souvient de tout.
Il a en mémoire des millions
de gestes et de poses.
Le corps dispose d'une avance
incroyable sur la machine.
Même si la machine
pourra peut-être nous remplacer
sur les grands principes de pensée,
elle ne remplacera jamais
les actes du corps.
Regardez vos mains.
Vos mains ont 360 millions d'années.
Le pouce opposable pour la préhension,
55 millions d'années.
Nos corps ont été façonnés
depuis les origines de la vie.
Le philosophe Michel Serres disait :
« Qui invente ?
Le corps.
Qui expérimente ?
L'intelligence reste bête
et lourde sans le corps. »
Ce soir, entre bioprogressistes
et bioconservateurs,
j'ai fait mon choix.
La meilleure façon de devenir
un Homme augmenté,
c'est de se reconnecter à son corps.
Alors ce soir à tous,
je vous pose la question :
et vous,
quel est votre choix ?
Merci.
(Applaudissements)